حماس ليست جماعة إرهابية أوه،
ليست سيدتي أولا، حماس ليست
جماعة إرهابية، حماس ليست جماعة إرهابية،
ما هو مثل مقاومة نادي الدراجات النارية،
إنها مقاومة
تشتعل منذ 75 عاما من الاستعمار
الاحتلال والقتل واغتصاب
الأطفال الصغار من النساء، هذا ما
هم عليه، إنهم مقاومة، هل تعتقد أن
كندا دولة استعمارية
أيضًا كل ما يفعلونه له ما يبرره
بما في ذلك ما حدث الأسبوع الماضي، كل
شيء فعلوه له ما يبرره،
لذا سيدتي  كان هناك أطفال مقتولين، كان هناك
أطفال
مقطوعة الرأس، أطفال مقطوعة الرأس حقًا، يرجى
تثقيف نفسك، يرجى التحقق من الأخبار
لأنه كمراسل إخباري عليك
التحقق من الأخبار لأنهم قالوا إن
هذا القرف كان مزيفًا، حسنًا عدة مرات،
قنوات مختلفة مختلفة حتى بايدن
نفسه ووزرائه
وقال أغبياءه بنفسه إن تلك الأخبار كاذبة،
لا يوجد 40 طفلًا برؤوس، ولا
يوجد 1300 حالة وفاة، لا يوجد دليل،
لا يوجد دليل، لا توجد صور على
الإطلاق، حماس مسلمة،
جماعة مسلمة، لن يفعلوا ذلك أبدًا لأنه
مخالف للإسلام، هذا رقم واحد
وهذا شيء يظهرونه،
تصدق حقًا أن هناك أدلة على
قول نساء إسرائيليات إنهم أعطونا
الماء، أعطونا طعامًا، أعطونا
مكانًا للنوم بشكل
مريح، أعطونا ملابس،
جلبوا لهم لتسترهم، احترامًا لهذا
هل النساء الحقيقيات اللاتي أجرين مقابلات
يتحدثن عن الوقت الذي كن فيه رهائن أو
عندما شعرن
بالأسف عندما كان أعضاء حماس
يأتون إلى منزلهن، هذه
نساء إسرائيليات حقيقيات يقلن أن هذا هو حالهن
حتى في مرحلة ما
قال أحد مقاتلي حماس لأحدهن  هل يمكن للنساء
تناول موزة لأكلها، فسأل إذا كان
بإمكانه تناول الموز الموجود في
منزلها، هل يبدو هذا بمثابة عمل إرهابي
بالنسبة
لك؟